お釈迦様おっしゃった2番目の真理っていうのは
なんで人間に苦しみがあるんでしょうかと
例えば 欲しがるものは得られないっていうのは苦しみですよと
大変わかりやすいことで
なんで欲しがるものは得られないことは苦しみですかね
だから苦しみの原因なのかと
だからそれは欲しがる
欲しがるものは得られない
だから苦しみっていうわけじゃないんですよ
それは因果法則はちょっと甘く見ているんです
だから瞑想する時でも
みんな偉そうにいる こうではないか
ああではないかとか 全部くだらん
もう何の意味もないんです
そんなものは因果法則でもなんでもないんです
ですから そういうことではなくてね
やっぱり人が苦しんでいる
悩んでいる なんで苦しんでいる
悩んでいるかと見れば
色々欲しいものがありまして
それは得られないと その時はかなり悩んじゃうんですね
どう頑張っても自分が欲しがるものを
希望するものは自分のものになりません
世の中でそっちはあることで
ですから なんでその時苦しみが生まれるんですかね
あるいは答えとして人間に欲しがるものはあればいいと
その希望 何でしたっけ？願望を実現すればいいでしょうと
そう思うアホな人々はいます
願望 願望が実現したら幸福で幸せやと言って
呪文唱えるは 題目唱えるは
もうやりたい放題のこと
くだらんことをやってます
誰の願望を実現してないんですよ
そんなことをやっても
全部 もしあるならば言ってみてください
何々さんの願望は全部実現しましたと
何か経典をあげたんだから
何かお祈りしたんだから
何か行をやったんだから
そんなことで願望を実現するんだったら
人間仕事をする必要ないんですよ
畑耕す必要ないんです
ご飯食べたいと言ってお祈りすればいいでしょうに
お釈迦様はそういう話は全然してないんですよ
すごいこのわかりやすく
もう頭にぶん殴ってるんですよ
このもう無知に無知の塊の頭に
で なんででしょうかと
そこでお釈迦様が発見したすごい 2番目の真理っていうのは
渇愛っていう一言葉なんですよ
渇愛っていう欲があるんですね
それは欲なんですけどね
で 人間の心の問題は渇愛だよと
それが私が発見しましたと
いまだかつてなかった真理だよと
いまだに誰にもこれが発見できなかったと
目が覚めたと 悟り開いたと
そう言っても みんなすごい軽く見る
まあそうですね そういえば欲出しちゃうと
ちょっと苦しみですよとかね
わかったようなふりをする
それでわかって悟った人はいますかね
で やっぱりそれはものすごいこの人間の知恵を
知識レベルを乗り越えている発見なんですよ
発見ですけど 具体的に我々の日常生活の中からも
いくらか いくらかではなくて
しっかりと発見できる真理なんですね
だからこの一つの真理わかっちゃえば 2番目もわかってしまうんですよ
そこら辺はまあ頭でわかることで
知恵でわかることで ワンセットなんですよ
わかっただけで問題は解決しません
それからもうちょっと頑張らないと
それは 3番目と 4番目の真理で真理で成り立っているんです
だから生きることはドッカであると
苦しみであるとわかったならば
もう渇愛っていうのは成り立たないんですね
だから この無意識的に生きることの苦しみっていうのは
まあ一応頭の中にあるんです
無意識的にも意識的にも
結局この気がつかないだけ苦しんでもがいているんです
苦しんでもがいてるんですけど
気がついてないんだから
結局あっちこち走り回ってるだけ
迷路の中で もう何も研究しない
何も観察能力ない ただ走り回るだけで
うん まあそういうことだから
まあ一生懸命みんなこのいい加減な推理を作るんですね
私にとっては今お金がないと
お金がないんだから大変苦しいと
それでじゃあお金があればその苦しみが消えるそうと
それでお金儲かることに大変苦労する
その苦労はもう全部なかったことにする
お金儲けるための苦労っていうのはほとんど気にしない
儲かったらもう幸せになるんだそうと
それでお金儲かったことで幸せになったっていうことはまあないんですよ
世の中で 私にはお金があるんだ
だから何の問題もないんだと言う人がいるならば
だからみんな嘘つきだから言わないだけで
我々もアホだからお金ある人を見て
ああ羨ましいと あの人には何の問題もないだろうと好き勝手に考えるだけであって
お金入ったからといって苦しみが消えないんですよ
逆にまたいろいろいろいろ問題が増えるだけ
で またある人がまた何か言うでしょうに
私には結婚できれば幸せやと
それで結婚して それで全ての人生の幸せを手に入りますかね
入れませんでしょうに
結婚したんだからといって不幸になっている人々もいるでしょうに
お金があったことで不幸になる人々もいるでしょうに
だからそこら辺には答えあるわけじゃないんです
で 一つ得ると次に出てくる問題は
問題が増えるだけ 寂しいんだから犬を飼う
寂しくないんですね 犬がいるんだから
それで問題解決しますかね
それから犬も面倒見なくちゃいけないでしょうに
別な苦しみが増えるんですよ
それでそれからありとあらゆる苦しみが増えるんですよ
犬に散歩させなくちゃいけないし
治療してあげなくちゃいけないし
お風呂に入れてあげなくちゃいけないし
それでその犬の性格は自分に合わなかったら
またまたいろいろ不満が出たりする
そこで散歩すると あの他の人々の犬見たりするでしょうし
それで比較するし そうすると他の犬には色々芸ができて
もっとすごい豪華な犬とかね
この犬は百万円やもう百万円やとかね
まあいるんですよ そうすると自分の犬は二万円ですよって言っちゃうとね
これでまた新しい苦しみが増えちゃうでしょうね
で それでまあ人間の生き方っていうのはそんな風な生き方で
で 苦しみ増える方法だけで考えてるんですね
ですから それもお釈迦様おっしゃってるんですよ
人間が苦しんでいて あの苦しみをなくしたいと希望はしてますよと
希望して苦しみを作るものが何なのかと探して
それは探し求めているんだと
で  これがあれば苦しみが消えるぞと苦しみを作るものを探し求めているんだと
それはまあ人間の探検
ブッダの探検はもっとまた違うんだと
だから人類の探検はそういうものでしょうしね
財産欲しいとかね 長生きしたいとかね
年は取りたくないとと言って何やってるんでしょうかと
まあとにかく愛っていうことが心にありますね
この渇愛っていうのは
まあ結局は生きていきたいという
この気持ちですね とにかく生きていきたいと
生きていきたいと思うんだけど
生きてるということは何でしょうかね
どういうことに我々は生きているというんでしょうかね
それも考えてみますかね
はっきりと生きるということはこういうことですよと
ですから それはすごいいいことですよと
最高の素晴らしいことですよと
ですから 生きていきたいというならば
本質的なんです 生きるということはどういうことか
一度も一回でも考えたことがありますか？と考えたこともない
ただ大雑把で なんと素晴らしいですかと
なんと素晴らしいと言った途端
はっきりと聞かなくちゃあかんですよ
何がなぜ素晴らしいというんですかと
その なんで人間っていうのはこの合理性ないかっていうのはすごい問題なんですね
何だかんだもう大雑把で
で 全然証拠いらんですね
人間何か喋る時でも 証拠なしに喋れば喋るほど信頼してくれる
証拠を持って喋ると聞きたくないという
だから私は神であると言っちゃうと
もう三ヶ月間でもう百万人も信者さん作るんです
私には超能力あるんだぞと言ったら
もうもういくらでももう信者さんが集まるんですね
ですからもうすごい簡単ですよ
証拠だけ言うな 本当かないかと調べるなよと
そうすると言うことを信じる
だから皆様にもすぐもう神様になれますよ
まあいい加減なことを言えばそれだけのことで
私に毎日夜神々が来てこう言います
ああ言いますとかね 世紀末論みたいに
あのノストラダムスの予言みたいに
ノストラダムスというあの愚か者が本当に予言したんですかね
何一つも予言してないんですけど
ただの詩人でしょうね
詩人っていうのはいろいろ妄想していろんなものを書く
それで もうもう詩一つ読む能力ないバカどもたちが
これは予言だ 予言だとか
もうちょっと勉強すればいいでしょうに
文学とか まあとにかくはっきりしないことが素晴らしく思うという
この理屈ないところがね
大変なことなんですね
ですから この生きていきたいという希望がある
その希望も同じく愚かな希望なんですよ
なぜ愚かな希望かというと
生きていきたいと思うならば
まず生きるということを研究して
それは素晴らしいことであると証明出してから
故に欲しいと言わなくちゃあかんですね
その明確性っていうのは必要なんですよ
だから仏教は宗教でないと私は言うのはそういうわけなんです
いつでもこの具体性 論理性
明確であるかと それはいつでも問うんですね
曖昧はダメですよと 中途半端
それもダメですよと 希望もダメです
私はそういう希望ですよと
私はこんな好みです いい加減にしなさいと
必要なのはあなたの好みじゃなくて真理だよと
人が腐ってるものを食べるのは好みの人もいるかもしれませんよ
だからといってみんな腐ってるものを食べる必要あるんですかね？人の好みっていうのはもうどうでもいいことで
ですから このやっぱり具体性
論理性っていうのはね
明確 明晰であるということは大変期待するんですね
まあそういうことだから
生きるということは何なのかと分かっているならば
まあその人が生きることは素晴らしいというならば
まあ考えてみてもよろしいんですよ
では 世の中のありとあらゆるすべての学問
知識 調べてみてください
生きるということは説明していますかと
この私にもいろいろ教えてあげようとしている方々もよくよく見えますけどね
私に教えてくれる前に
私もうボロボロ老人だから今は
もう教えて勉強したくないんです
二十歳になるともうもうもうもう無茶苦茶やりたいことを全部やって終わっちゃったんです
みんな色々詳しがるんですけどね
だいたい人よりは 20倍早くやるんです
ですからまあもう読みたいものをやらね
まあそれはまあそういう昔
あのまあ落ち着かないんだからね
若い時はね でも意味のあるものは一つも見つからなかったんです
ただかえってもうもう人のもう一生研究して書いてる哲学であろうが
一言でバカにするんだから
かえって私が悪い人間になっただけ
評判が悪くなっただけ
うん まあたまにね まあすごいあの思想家っていうのはね
まあたまにいないわけじゃないんですよ
いることは確かにいます
みんなすごいっていうことじゃないんですね
でもそれでも私は気に入らん
例えばこのクリシュナムルティという人がいてね
結構立派なことを言うんですね
で 彼のまあ彼が弟子を作ってないんだけど
彼を信じて信仰しているという人がいるんですけど
私にはまあ言ってることはまあ別に問題ないんだけど
まあ気に入らん なぜかって
くちゃくちゃ言うんだけど
方法は持ってないんですね
方法論を持ってないと何の役にも立たんでしょうに
喋るだけで だったら黙っていろと
病気だ病気だ 病やったのに治すほかないんだよと
でもあんた病気です どうでもいいことで治すほかなかったら
治す方法ないんだったら黙ってりゃいいでしょうに
だからまあまあ 本当にいいことを言ってはいるんですけどね
他のあんまりないんですね
ですから この生きるということは何なのかとちゃんと分析して説明している人がいますかと
この世の中で 一人もいません
見てみると だからまあ私もやっぱり一応哲学の一つとして仏教を昔学んだんですからね
やっぱり比較できる 対照できる教えがないんですね
一つも 何一つも見つからない
西洋的でいえば いくらかこの論理だけですね
まあだからその論理で仏教は分析できるかっていうから
それは非常に簡単に分析できる
論理っていうのは理屈ですからね
数学と同じですからね
うん だから生きるってこと
例で考えれば簡単なことでしょうしね
例えば人々がね まあダイヤやらね
プラチナやらね そういうものを欲しがると
で なんで欲しがるんだ
まあ高価なものだからと
といえば その間では論理成り立ってますよ
ダイヤとかね そういう金のあるこの国にどこに持って行ったっていうのも
まあ高価なものなんですね
金がない国に持って行ったって意味がないんです
まあですからまあ自分も欲しいと
で 具体性があるんですよ
そのポイントだけで見ると
そうやって人生が素晴らしいものだというと
何かありますかと だからこれ研究しなくちゃいけないんですよ
あるかないかっていうのは
ですから 研究もしないで生きていきたいと思う
だからどうにもならないんですね
生きていきたいと思うんだけど
じゃあ それからよくよく見ると
人間っていうのは 生きていきたいと思ったって
もう結局はそれもわかってないんです
すごいきつい この死を恐れる気持ちがあるということにさえ気がつかないんですね
だからこれは発見できますよ
生きていきたいという人々にね
生きることは素晴らしいという人々に質問を出さなくちゃいけないんですよ
だから私が出すような質問だったら答えられないんです
怒るだけなんですね 相手が
ですから 逆に聞けばね
生き生きているとどんな素晴らしいことがあるんでしょうかと
具体的に言ってくださいと
何かありますかね 生きていると
生きていきたいっていう希望っていうのは普通あるでしょうね
あるんだったら なんで？そこら辺考えようともしない
そこら辺考えてみてくださいっていうのは
なんでそんなに生きていきたいの？なんで我々そんなに死を恐れるの？だから一人の人間もそれを考えてないんです
だから苦しみから脱出できないと
だからそこら辺はこの実践でもって考えさせていると思いますけどね
簡単に発見できますよ
もう私が言う通りに修行するんだったら
でも覚悟を決めてるんだから
言う通りにやらんという風に覚悟を決めてるんだから
まあしょうがないんですけどね
まあだからお釈迦様発見したのは
人間は結局はもうあの
わかってないだけで いろんなものを見たい
いろんなものを嗅ぎたい
いろんな音を聞きたい
いろんな味を味わいたい
体でいろんなものを触れてほしい
それだけのことですよ
そのために生きてきたからんです
それ発見するするとあまりにもバカバカらしいということになるんですよ
でもなかなかそれ見えませんね
生きているから なんだ素晴らしいこといっぱいあるんじゃないかと
まあいい いい いい なんというのかすごい大雑把で言うだけであって
どんな素晴らしいことをやったってね
それは見るものか聞くものか
食べるものか 嗅ぐものか
体に触れるものか どちらかでしょうに
この必死になって地球を破壊して何やってますかというと
この見るもの 聞くものを作ってるでしょうに
それわかってないんだから
自然を破壊するんですよ
時々家族は人  2  3人はいないんだけど
家を造る 部屋数は 40ぐらいあるとかね
そこであっちこっち別荘まで作る
なんて素晴らしいですかと
生きることはとかね 何やってるんですかね
そういうことをするんだから
世の中みんなさらに苦しくなるでしょうに
楽しいんだからといって
もういろいろもう高級車集まる人々いるでしょうに
こんな 5  6台  7台  8台の車あるんだからといって
ただ車の手入れしているアホだけでしょうに
どこに行くんですかね
どこへ行ったっても 1台の車でしか行けないでしょうに
そこで月曜日はこの車
火曜日はこの車で変えたんだからって
何が変わるんですかね
それで何か人生で何か変わる？だからそういう生き方っていうのは
愚か者の生き方だよと
車 10台ぐらいあれば
まあ見るところはちょっと変わるかもしれません
座るところこっちもちょっと変わるかも
だからそれ見ることと体で感じることだけでしょうに
結局その 2つなんですよ
だからまあ だからお釈迦様は眼耳鼻舌身に分析しているんです
それは並の分析じゃないんです
それでものすごく智慧が出てくるんです
誰が何やっても 目で見る
耳で聞く 鼻で嗅ぐ 舌で味わう
体で感じると それだけでしょうに
それが欲しくて追っていくんです
だから体がなかったらね
そんなものはね 目がなかったら見えないでしょうに
だから目があってほしいと目に対してすごく欲張っちゃうんです
鼻で香りは嗅げないと
ものすごくまあ楽しみが消えるんだ
だよと それで生きたがるだけのことなんですよ
そんなにすごい遠い わかりにくい
大変なことじゃないんです
これ単純なことを見えないのは素晴らしい頭があるんだからなんです
天国の真理探してるんです
で それで逆に我々の眼耳鼻舌身っていうのは
我々をどうしているんですかというと
結局奴隷にしているだけ
いっぱいものを見たんだからといって
その人に何か変わることがあります？何も変わることはないんですよ
一生音楽聴いてるんだからといって何か変わりますか？何も変わりません
ただ頭が悪くなるだけ
もっとアホになるだけ
あまり聞きすぎと耳が悪くなる
あまりにも見すぎると目が悪くなる
あまりにも食べ物に執着しちゃうと何も食べられなくなる
大変なことになりますよ
体が だからいくら頑張ってもリミットがありますよ
で 必ずしもそれから目やら耳やら鼻やら老化するんですね
で 老化して壊れていく
そのための人生 ほとんどの苦しみは
まあそれで苦しみっていうのは生まれてくる
ですから 渇愛の 1番目はそれなんで五欲なんですね
眼耳鼻舌身に依存していること
まあ 2番目はね 生きていきたいという欲であってね
バワタンナというんですけどね
3番目は嫌なものはまあ潰しちゃおうと
という破壊的な欲なんですよ
自分にとって嫌なものを潰して潰してね
懐疑主義で破壊主義者でもう生活したっても
それで救われますか？救われませんでしょうに
それでも老老病死あるでしょうに
ただ それで苦しみが増えるだけでしょうに
じゃあ体を楽しめよと
眼耳鼻舌身 一生懸命いじることで結局苦しみが増えるだけで
だからやっても苦しみが
やらなくたっても苦しみが生まれてくるようなセットなんですよ
そういうことで 問題は渇愛であると
それは取り除いちゃうと
簡単に取り除ける これ全てこの
そんな問題よとわかれば
まあ渇愛が薄くなって消えてしまうんです
それで心落ち着くんです
それはなんで大胆な真理でしょうかというと
これぐらいは心理学者にも発見できますよと
できません ちょっと心の問題を言ってるんだから
だったらもうギリギリギリギリ科学的な西洋心理学で発見できますでしょう
できません 全く発見できていない
発見するどころか ユングという人っていうのは何言ってるんですかと
むちゃくちゃでしょう
言ってることは その人が日本で一番心理学の世界で人気人気人気
日本の心理学者はもうすべてユングの
はもう宗教ですよ まあ博士号は 1つと 2つ 3つ持ったりとかね
ドイツで 5年研究しましたと
フランスで 3年研究します
本当にこの学者としてはもうもうなかなかあの人々なんですけどね
あまりにもアホくさくて喋りたくもならないぐらいね
本当に問題の 私もいろいろいくつかの本まで買ってみたんだけどね
そのあるバカがね もうすごい有名な教授ですけど
キリスト教になりまして
で 神を信仰することと
神の存在と ユングのもう心理学のね
まあどれほど似ているかという話を語ってるんですね
私が言うたら あんた日本人だからね
何も宗教も何もなくて
宗教はないぞと言った方がもっとかっこいいんじゃないかと
普通の若者っていうのはそれでカッコつけてますよ
全然宗教ないんだぞと
あれも結構私はなかなかかっこいいと思いますよ
何か宗教に入るんだったら
もうちょっとしっかりした
あんな原始的な宗教信仰したって
あるいは日本人だから私は神社に行くぞと言っちゃうと
まあどうしようもないんです
日本人だからしょうがないんだから
そういうところでもなくてね
ただカッコつけようと思って
本当にもう読んでももったいないゴミぐらいの話なんですね
それをゴミを語るためにすごい苦労するんですよ
ものすごい研究する ものすごい研究して書いてますけど
もう結局は何の役にも立たないゴミ
それでじゃあ心理学者
人の人間の心の問題解決するかというと
全然解決もしない 死の恐怖感に対して誰が答えを持ってますかね
誰も答えを持ってないんですね
であの読んだある科学科学記事にあった話なんですけど
この まあ生命に期待しているのはただ子孫を作ることだけですよと
ただそのために生きているんだよと
それで子孫を作った途端
もうお払い箱やと だから産んだ子供を独り立ちできるまでは誰でも元気なんですよ
腰も痛くない まあ体も壊れません
夜寝られなくても大丈夫です
体力あるんです そこで見てください
人間の世界でも動物の世界でも
この繁殖能力消えちゃうとどうなるんですかと
その瞬間から体が壊れて壊れて壊れてゴミ箱に行くんです
それは仏教の話じゃないんです
それはもうちゃんとした科学者が書いた記事で
私は読んだところですけど
私もずっとそんなこと言っていたんだけど
最近読んだ記事にそういう風にも書いてありましたし
新しいデータがいっぱい入っていたものでね
我々は昔からもそんなことは言ってますけどね
それでそんなに大胆なすごいことですかね
子孫を作ること 必死になって子孫を作る
命かけて子孫を作る 作られた者が何するかというと
命かけて子孫を作る その作られた者が何するかというと
命かけて子孫を作る そればっかしでしょうに
うん だから我々は奴隷になってしまって子孫作れと
しょうがない まあまあ
自分が奴隷だったらしょうがないと思って子孫作るでしょうに
じゃあ自分が大事にすることは子孫がどうなるんですかね
それも奴隷なんです 結局それも奴隷になって子孫を作ると
で Life on Earth という
まあこの地球の生命というのはそれぐらいのものだよと
だからその人が書いたかったのは
この人間がもう今寿命は延びているんですけど
これは科学的にはすごい無理があるんだと
寿命が延びるということはね
だからいろんな工夫して工夫して
人間の寿命がみるみるうちに延びていくんだと
延びてはいくんだけど
まあ結構まあ無理があるんだよと
それでも 無理っていうのは
まあ本当はもう繁殖能力なくなっちゃうと
もう終わりと いわゆる保証期間って言うんですか
保証期間 それで終わりと
我々は保証期間はもう 2倍伸ばして使っているんだと
だから保証効きません
繁殖能力ある間が保証期間ですね
骨折れたってもすぐ治ると
風邪引いてもすぐ治る
薬飲まなくたっても もう体に悪いものを食べたくても大したことない
大丈夫です 保証期間中だから
そこで飛んじゃうと まあ危険で危険で
女性の場合はね 本当に骨がなければ生きていられないでしょうね
そこでこの保証期間飛んだその日から骨はどうなるんですか
作らないんですよ だから何とか何とか病気やりますね
何て言います？彼は え？そういう
だから骨がボロボロなんですよ
まあ形はそんな形には中身ないんですよ
だからちょっとでも足が滑っちゃうと
もう折れちゃう 折れたらもう寝たきりになったりするでしょ
繋げないんですよ から骨がいっぱい溜まってると簡単に繋げるんです
じゃあそれだったら倒れなきゃいいでしょ
骨は何で支えてるんですか？筋肉
筋肉で支えてるんだ 筋肉どうなるんですかね
年取ると だから骨が弱くても筋肉がしっかりしてるんだったらもう倒れないで済みます
その通りでしょう 筋肉も
だからもう振ったり蹴ったり蹴ったりする状態なんです
だからそれに文句言ったあの科学者言うのは
まあそれ無理があるんだと
もう保証期間終わりんだよと
終わってるんだよと それで科学者やら医学者やら色々工夫して工夫して
まあまあ一応寿命を延ばしてはいるんですけど
結構無理だよと そこで体コントロールするのは脳細胞でしょうね
これが 28ぐらいになってくると
それからは死にかけていくんですね
毎日大量の脳細胞が死ぬ
それでどうしても手も足ももう言う通りに動いてくれないんです
だからその人生は最高に素晴らしいと
で だから我々には心に一応問題があります
でもこの生きることは結局死で終わるものだから
生命のゴールというのは死ぬことなんですよ
そこでゴールなんです
死んじゃった で終わり
じゃあ何やって生きてきたんですかと
何も大したことない もう見た
食べた 寝た 喧嘩した それだけなんですね
あるいはいっぱいゴミを拾ったとかね
死ぬ時は 300 300億円資産がありましたとかね
それで喜ぶバカもいるんです
私はこのバカがすごいゴミ拾い拾ったんではないかと
だって持っていけないんだから
その人にとっては何の役にも立たんでしょうに
資産 300億円あろうとも
もっとあろうとも 1万円しかなかったとしたっても同じでしょうに
死ぬ時はもう まあ生きる間でも
まあそれそれしかしてない
頭はただそれだけにしか使ってない
財産と名誉と権力 普通の人々は
まあそれは特別な人々
普通の人々は健康と長生きと
まあ老後は心配しないぐらいのお金という
それ一つ目られますかね
健康は？長生きは？何一つ目られません
だから人間にはちょっとね
まあ思考っていうのはね
もう直すか直さないと
このこの勢いの生き方っていうのは騙されてるだけですよっていうのはブッダの教えなんですね
まあお釈迦様はそういう同じ言葉で仰ってないんですけどね
まあそれはまあ私の言葉に変えると
私の言葉で言ったって
これ日本語でわかりやすい言葉に変えると
まあ騙されてるだけ あまりにも騙されてる
気が付かない 死ぬ瞬間でも一秒でも生き延びたいという
ただそれだけで よくもそう思うもんだから
あと一分だけでも生き延ばせばいいんじゃないかなと
と思うぐらい もうあまりにも騙されてるんですよ
だからそこら辺は客観的に具体的に見てくださいと
見たらすぐ分かりますよと
なんで見ないのかと なんで神にすがるんですかと
そのすがること自体でも
もう完璧な無知っていうことはもう自分でも認めてるんですよ
それはやっぱり生きることは素晴らしいと
でもちょっとまあちょっと生きづらいんだと
助けてくれということなんですね
それでこの三種類の渇愛ね
体を刺激する渇愛と生きていきたいという渇愛と
嫌なものは破壊してやるぞと
その方が楽や楽やと 敵を潰すという怒りの欲ですね
その三つで生きてるんだと
それで苦しみが増えるんだ
心からその三つを取り除けばいいんじゃないかなと
という話です それで それがなんで大胆な話かというと
いろんな意味で大胆な話なんですよ
一つ誰も言ってない 誰も発見していない
いくら頑張っても 人間のこのこの思考では発見できません
どんな機械作って宇宙はああだこうだとかね
もう言うでしょうに もうもう
月のでもコロニー作りましょうとか
それくらいのことで そちらに月で火星でコロニー作ったってもう同じことの繰り返しでしょうに
将来の人間が火星に住んでるんだからっていったって
我々にとっては何の関係もないことでしょうに
そこでその人々は その将来の人間どうするんですか？同じことでしょうに
喧嘩したり もうもう嫌なものは潰したり
好きなものは拾ったり
年取って死ぬだけ それにはものすごい苦労しなくちゃいけない
逆に科学が発展すればするほど
生きることは苦しくなるんですよ
大変なことになる 簡単には生きていられなくなります
で 科学者は客観的な研究をしているんだから
その分は間違ってはないんですよ
土やらいろんなものを研究して
研究して まあまあ こういうことでこうなってるんだ
こういうことでこうなってるんだっていうのは分はいいんだけど
生命って命っていうことは勉強しないんだからね
今日のニュースで出ましたけど
このあの痴呆になる患者さんのね
遺伝を調べて まあ痴呆になる遺伝を見つかりましたと
それは日本の研究ですけど
まあありがたい話ですね
で まだもうまだまだ ただ一つの遺伝だけちょっと変化しているということでね
一個だけ で まだその中でまだまだまだ研究しなくちゃいけないし
で まあただ写真撮って写真撮って写真撮ってみると
まあ一個がちょっとおかしいと
で まだまだ遺伝子治療が発展してないんですね
すごい将来のことで そこで遺伝子治療がもしかするとね
発展して普通に使えるようになったならば
痴呆になりかかっている子供たちにその遺伝子治療をして痴呆にならないようにすることはできます
あと何十年かかるかわかりませんだけど
ではそれでどうなるんですかね
一人の人が痴呆にならなくて
それはそれだけでしょうね
我々と同じく痴呆だからね
別に それで普通に学校に行って勉強して
普通に結婚して仕事をして
苦労して死ねると ただそれだけの結果なんですよ
まあ考えてみれば まあ子供を産んだ母親にしたら
父親にしたら やっぱり痴呆の子供だったらこれは治してほしいっていうのはありがたい話かもしれませんですけど
それでもし治して治してしたっても
ごく普通の人間でバカで生きてるだけなんですね
苦労しながら 痴呆だったらしない苦労はしなくちゃいけないんですよ
痴呆の人も痴呆だから
いろいろ生きることは大変でしょうし
いろいろ苦労しますけどね
苦労が変わるだけ 痴呆で苦しむか普通に苦しむかと
それでもう一つ問題があるんですよ
その治療にかかるお金
どんどん医療費が高くなるんですよ
新しい薬作らないと古い薬効かなくなってるんだからね
使いすぎて そうするとすごく高くなっていく
あの手術するロボット
今は開発しているでしょうに
すごい体に負担もなくてね
ただ体の中で穴三つ開けて
それでロボットが手術する
医者がもう手術するのをロボットを操縦するのは医者ですけど
もう何のこともなく 大きなモニターでできるだけ大きくして見て
それで自分でコンピューターゲームやってるような感じで
機械を動かせばいいんです
だから手術終わったら小さな穴を塞いでおけば
それで終わり 次には家に帰ると
どんな大きい手術でも
例えばとにかく今日本であるみたいです
その機械いくつかのね
大阪の病院とか でも手術代はまあ
五百万 八百万とかね それぐらいかかっちゃうんですね
だからね 普通の人には保険は利きませんね
でお金あればまあ幸せですけど
なかったのと わかってなければもう大変苦労しなくちゃいけないし
もし 全ての病院はじゃあこれでいいやと思って取り入れちゃうと
一般人がどうしますか
金がない人々は だから機械自体は悪くないんですよ
問題はまあ それの使用方法なんですね
だから結局私たちに次に出てくる課題が
手術するために百万あるいは万円払うために
我々はお金貯めておかなくちゃいけない
その分が仕事を増やす
その分が仕事をしなくちゃいけない
その分また自然破壊しなくちゃいけない
その分また搾取しなくちゃいけないと
だから結局何も貢献したことにならないんですよ
こちらで五百円くれると
もう自分のポケットから千円取るんだから
だからプラスにはならないんですよ
プラスになってるんだぞということは一つの幻覚なんです
だから科学発展することは
まあ自然法則で人間に欲がある限りそれはやってます
それはもうどうにもならないことでね
で 全く科学なんかなくても
別に人間っていうのは自然の中で生きていられますよ
だって一緒に我々と一緒に進化していけた動物たちは
何の科学もなく生きているでしょうに
何のコンピューターも電卓さえないんです
で生きていられるし ですから結局は大きなお世話ですよ
あんなものは 我々はお金を使うようになったんだから
計算しなくちゃいけなかっただけで
それは発展 発展やと言ったっても
お金使うんだから計算するだけのこと
それでまあまあ なんていうのはそろばんも発展
発見して それからそろばんも遅いやと
また怠けちゃって じゃあ電卓でやるぞと
またそれでも計算できないぞと
それでコンピューターでやるぞという風になっただけのことですね
そんなことなかったらなかったら人間生きていられないかというと
生きていられないわけじゃないんです
で じゃあ医学発展しなかったらどうしますかと
ほとんどこの我々社会壊したんだから出ている病気であって
もし自然の中で生きてならば
生きていたらこんな病気はないでしょうに
それだったら喘息もないし
アレルギーもないし 糖尿病もないし
がんもないでしょうに
まあそれなりの何かの病気で死ぬだけのことです
だから結局はもう科学は発展しているんだけど
プラスになってない なんでプラスになってないんでしょうかというと
やっぱりこのこの心の問題は発見してないんですね
だから やっぱりこの生きることって何なのかとかね
渇愛のこととかね よく分かった上で行動したならば
本当にプラスになるはずなんです
それ分かってないんだから
我々にとって役に立たないんですね
で それ一つ それやって
この科学発展からいろんなことあるんだけど
科学者さえも いくら宇宙望遠鏡で宇宙を見ても
この人間の苦しみが渇愛で生まれてくるんだっていうことだけ発見できないんですね
望遠鏡でなぜ宇宙を覗いているかというと
渇愛だから 渇愛だからですよと
足らない足らないと ただそれだけのことをやって
それは見えないんですよ
だからお釈迦様の教えがすごい大胆なんです
誰も見てない でも必ず見ておく必要あるポイントを見せてあげるんですね
もう一つ 渇愛あるのは私の心でしょう
私が渇愛を持ってるんです
誰かが作ったわけじゃないんです
物を見て食べて それで私の欲が生まれたんであって
誰かがご飯食べさせて欲作れなさいよと教えたわけじゃないでしょうに
赤ちゃんたちに我々教えるんですかね
これを欲張ってくださいとかね
ただ赤ちゃんおもちゃ見たら面白いと目で見るんだからね
赤ちゃんにとってはこの色って薄いが違うんですよ
で 大人と違うんですね
色の薄いが 覚えていますかね
赤ちゃんの時 どういう風に見えたんですかね
世の中 なんで忘れるんですかね
覚えておいた方がいいんです
ものすごい違う見え方なんです
まあ大人の言葉で言えばすごい大胆に見える
色は 何だかわからない
とにかく で 概念ないでしょうに
ただ直接そこに色を映しちゃうんですね
それでも体いっぱい感動して大胆に見えちゃう
で それでそのオモチャをじーっとねじっちゃうんです
それで欲はできてます
誰かが強引に欲を教えたわけじゃないんです
ものすごいもう執着はもうその瞬間に生まれているんです
心の汚れは大人と同じなんです
テディベア もうボロボロになってるテディベアを抱っこしてもういる子供と
もう財産 会社やらね そんなもので死にかけてる大人と大して差がないんですよ
欲は 子供のテディベアでもぬいぐるみでも取ってみてください
どれぐらい精神的にショックを受けるかというと
治らないんですよ だからちっちゃな子供たちっていうのは
時々いろいろガラクタ集めて
これガラクタだから捨てましょうと私は平気で言うんですよ
じゃあこれは捨てましょう
ガラクタだからと 言っちゃうとすごい顔が真っ赤になっちゃって
まあ大変なこと で 何ですかね
これは私のことはすごい大事ですよと
あ そう じゃあ宝物ですか
じゃあ自分で守りなさいよ
言って向こうに でなきゃこちらに任せるんだからね
ガラクタ守ることは 私は子供の面倒は自分でやりません
全部本人に任せる そのために聞くんですけど
だから子供にはちょっと心配かけてあげるんです
これちょっとなんとか置いてくださいとか
大人に頼んだっても この人はちょっとやべえと
ガラクタって言ってるんだから
で 自分のものは自分で守る
そういう風に まあまあ
それはまあ 子供扱いのやり方ですけどね
でも結局はもっと客観的に
もっとクールにものを見ると
欲は同じなんですね だから私が持ってるものが子供から見ればガラクタなんですよ
その同じ子供が私に言ったらね
じゃああんた持ってるこれこれとかね
これは全然役に立たんガラクタだから捨てなさいよと
あんたのカバンはガラクタだから捨てなさいよと言っても
私は冗談じゃないよと
これは大事なものやと言うんでしょうしね
だから同じことなんですね
だからお父さんの宝物は
子供にとっては何のこともないゴミで
子供の宝物はお父さんにとってはゴミで
でもその二人については
それは大変な大事な宝物で
だから言いたかったのは
この欲っていうのは誰も教えて
誰かが我々の体にこの欲というウイルスを注入したわけじゃないんですよ
心に ただ心にそういう欲が生まれたんです
情報に触れて その教えがなぜ大胆かというと
で いろいろ世の中の宗教が人間の苦しみの原因は語ろうとはするんだけど
はっきり語ってないんですね
例えば西洋だったら神を裏切ったんだと
だから我々罪人やと言うんですね
そうすると 自分のせいじゃないんですね
罪がこの神との関わりで成り立っているものなんですね
だからこちらが裏切ったんだから
向こうが許してくれない限りは
もうどうにもならないんですよ
で 私が人を殴ったならば
私は悪いことをしているでしょうに
で 私はあれ忘れましたよと
好き勝手に忘れたんだからって問題解決しないでしょうに
あんた私を殴ったでし
え？いいえ 私忘れましたそれは
だからいちいちうるさいうるさいことを言うなよと言ったっても成り立たないでしょう
あるいは私は人から万円借りる
借りて まあそれ使って
1ヶ月とか経ったら その人はお金はちょっと早く早く返ってくだ
お金ってどんなお金？ 1ヶ月とか前
あんたに貸してあげたでしょう
ああ  1ヶ月とか前 ああ
もう忘れちゃった じゃああんた返ってください
もう 言って問題解決しますかね
だから相手を他人を裏切ったんだから
私勝手には決して救われません
もし私が人から万円も借りても
その人がまあいいや もうそれはもうあなたにあげますよと言ったら
もうこちらにも罪はないでしょうに
いいよ まあうるさいんだから
もう返してくれるわけでもないし
あなたに払う能力もないし
まあ許してあげると 人を殴った時も同じことでしょうに
殴られた側が被害者が許してくれると許したことになるんです
だからその論理で神が許してくれない限り
人間には救いがないんだと平気で言ってるんです
ということは 自分の救いは自分の能力
努力で成り立たないんだと
あなた方は虫けらみたいなもんだよと
罪人やと 許してもらいなさいよと
許してくれとかくれないかっていうのは
それは向こうの勝手だから
だからそれで永久的に人間を奴隷にすると
それは全く非科学的 だってはっきりした証拠はいまだにないんだからね
何かの神みたいな存在
どんな神でもいいんですけど
この宇宙は作ったんだよとかね
ただ誰かさんがもう勝手に言ってるだけであって
それも古い古い人間が言ってることであって
現代人がこのすごい抜群の能力ある科学者やら哲学者やら
そんなこと言わないでしょうに
だから昔のもう精神的な病気な人々が言ったことだから
どうしても当てにならない
もし現代で人が言うならば
一人だけ日本にいますけど
私が神ですよとね でも何一つもできない
その人も精神的な病気なんですけどね
ですから この だからお釈迦様の発見というのは大発見なんですね
原因は私の心にあるんだと
渇愛は私の心にあるんだから
これ誰か強引に作ることはできません
例えばウナギっていうのは美味しい食べ物かもしれませんよ
食べたことがない人に
私は強引に口にさせて
これ食えと すごい美味しいんだよと言ったら
その人にそれを美味しく感じるんですかね
見るだけでも腹が立つんで
それからは たとえ美味しいものでも
強引に欲を作ることはできません
女性の方々よく失敗するんでしょ
そういうことで よく身振り手振りって言うんでしょ
いろんなものに男性の方目を引こうと
あまり強引にやっちゃうと嫌われちゃうんです
あまりしつこく 男を捕まえようとすると男が逃げちゃうんですね
それで もうもう関係ないやと
もう関係ないやと あっち向いてる女の方は男が追っていくでしょうに
だからもう煩悩の世界っていうのは
いつでも心理 そういう心理なんです
まあ静かに まあそれじゃニコッと笑って
まあ何のこともなく まああまり興味を見せないで黙ってる女性だったら
男の人はもう電話番号とかなんとか聞いて
とにかくもうそちらからアプローチする
女の方からアプローチしちゃうとモニエル
だから強引に欲作ることはできません
もう試しに男たちに聞いてみてください
私嫌いでしょ？すごいセクシーでしょうとかね
その時想像を総動員して言うかもしれませんだけど
それっきりもう会うこと
会う 会うことさえもできなくなると思います
逃げますよと あの女おかしいやと
だからやっぱり欲っていうのは自然に発生するものなんです
男の体にも 女の体にも
子供の場合でも同じだ
子供っていうのはもうどんなおもちゃも好きっていうわけじゃないでしょうに
それで今最近のおもちゃ
本物っていうのは 大人が金儲かるために作っているものでしょうに
あんまり子供に人気ないんですね
だから買ってはあげるんだけど
子供は見てすぐもう飽きちゃう
だから子供の頭の論理は考えてないんです
その子供の頭の論理考えてないんだから
このなかなか で 児童文学とか私もまあ読んでいろいろ見たんだけど
本当にこの書いてる人っていうのはものすごい素晴らしいんでしょ？と思ったんです
頭の悪さ 全然感動しないね
私は一応子供の思考っていうのはね
自分で子を変えてもう感じることできますからね
感じないだろうと思いますけど
でも昔話なんか未だにみんなもう一生懸命聞いたりするしね
私は今の年になっても
この子供に言う昔話なんか未だにすごい
もう  NHK で三局ででもね
もう昔話でも出ちゃうと
それはすぐ聞く すごい可愛いんでしょうしね
何か教えてくれるものもあるし
それまた子供と同じく何回聞いても飽きちゃう
飽きないんですよ それですごいSF映画やらいろんなものをものすごいもう億単位でお金使って作るでしょ
私は一回しか見ないんです
もう一回見るともう二度とはダメと
もう積もらない 全く でも桃太郎の話とかね
それはもう三回でも聞くと四回でも別に面白いです
何でしょうかね そちらにある
やっぱり昔の人々はね
やっぱりこの子供の気持ちをよく理解してね
子供が大人になってほしいと
その愛情で語った物語なんですね
金儲けたいと思わなかったんですよ
おばあちゃんは  それは置いておいて
で 私たちの苦しみの原因は私たちの心にあるんであります
ということは それはすごい救いの教えなんですよ
なんとかなるんだぞということ
なんとかなります 自分の心を磨き
磨けば見れば そのウイルスを取り除くことはできます
それは借金じゃないんです
裏切ったことでも誰も裏切ってないんです
人間は生きる上でいっぱい罪を犯してるんだけど
それはもう絶対的な誰かを裏切ったわけじゃないんです
それは業論でね それは別な話で
では業論でも人間の悟りに邪魔するなよっていうのはお釈迦様の教えなんですよ
で 業を信じていたこのインドの宗教ではね
やっぱり過去の業だからね
これは全部返さない限りはね
弁償しない限りは苦しみますよと
って言った教えもあるんですね
お釈迦様 それはちょっとおかしいんだ
そういうと だからこの過去の業
いくらあっても それは処理する
所さん何さんでしたっけ？清算する必要ないんです
問題は渇愛だから 渇愛取り除けば
まあ解脱を体験できるんだと
だから修行にはあんまり業っていうのはね
まあ気にしない 関係ない
業出す人々はまた同じく無知の話ばっかしで
で まあこれはあなたの業でしょうとかね
まあ業もわかってはないんですけどね
親が悪いことしたら子供にその業が来るわけじゃないし
戦争が悪いことしたんだからといって
子孫にそんなこと来るわけじゃない
業ってのはまた個人個人のことで
まあだからで 過去で過去で悪いことしたんだから
それは全部清算しない限りは幸せになりませんと言ったら
それまた嘘です 幸せにならないのは渇愛があるんだからなんです
苦しみ増えるのは渇愛あるんだから
ですから渇愛を消せばいいんです
まあそういうポイントっていうのは
大体はまあ世の中の思想と比べて考えるとね
大変な教えなんですよ
自分に責任があると言っちゃうと
みんな嫌がりますね 人のせやと言った方が気持ちいいんですよ
責任逃れだから そういうもう
もう本当に何の生き方ですかね
他人のせいだと だから世の中いつでもそんなことなんです
誰かのせいにする 自分が正しいと
だから業も他人のせいにすることなんです
過去の業だから今しょうがないと
だからブッダは まああなたのせいだよと
誰のせいでもないと  そういうことだから
やっぱり渇愛とあの三種類の渇愛っていうのはね
自分の心にあるもので
それもまあただ生きている上で生まれるもんなんですよ
渇愛生まれないようにはもうなかなか難しいんですよ
なぜならば すべてのものは不完全でしょう
だからおいしいご飯を食べても
そのご飯が不完全だから
もっとおいしいご飯があるんじゃないかという変な概念が生まれるんですよ
それも自分の体も不完全でしょうに
美味しさは完璧に味わうということはできないんですよ
誰かと喋っちゃうと頭がそちらに行くでしょうね
その時はもう感覚が鈍くなっちゃうんです
この その時その時の体の調子によって
例えばお腹に食べ物ある場合は
もう食欲に神経いかないんですよ
脳が忙しくて その時食べたってそんなに美味しく感じないんです
だから どう頑張っても食べ物の美味しさっていうのを百パーセント味わうということはありえない話で
無理な話で それで百パーセント味わっても
例えばおにぎり食べて
おにぎりの味を百パーセント味わう
百パーセント味わっても
そのおにぎり自体が不完全なものだから
味っていうのは もうご飯の炊き方から
もうおにぎり握った時からね
もう経っている時間によってずっと変わってるんだから
どんな時点で一番美味しいかっていうことをまだわかってないでしょうね
握った瞬間に美味しいか
握って時間経ったところで美味しいかとか
だからどんな時間のおにぎり取って食べても不完全な状態でしょうに
だから我々見るもの 聞くもの
すべて不完全なものだから
もっと美味しいものあるんじゃないかなという
もう渇愛が生まれるんですよ
それがもっと美味しいものあるんだなということは妄想であって
証拠ないことなんです
食べてのおにぎりだから
これはおにぎりの味ですと
それで止まればいいんですよ
いや もっとおいしいおにぎりあるはずでしょうと
と思っちゃう 綺麗な絵を見たらもっと綺麗な絵はあるはずでしょうしと
と思っちゃう ですから
同じ絵でも何回見ると飽きちゃうっていうことはあるんです
なぜ飽きるかというと
こちらも不完全で あちらも不完全で
刺激が少なくなる そうするともっと綺麗な絵があるんじゃないかなと思って
刺激求めて もう探し求めていくと
そうやって人間が食べるものを見るもの
聞くものをずっと必死になって探し求める
なぜかというと この不完全論がわかっていない
ドッカのもう一つの意味っていうのは
すべてのものは不完全
あなたも世界もすべて不完全だと
こんなくだらんことをやるなよと
やればやるほど渇愛が増えるだけですよと
ですから無常を発見しなさいと
ドッカを発見しなさいよと
渇愛を消しなさいよと
だから それほど具体的で合理的で
きちんと証明出して語っているという教えっていうのは
世の中ではないと思いますしね
他人のせいにもしないし
だからといって我々には途方に暮れる状態にもしてないんです
いつでも糸口を教えてあげる方法ありますよと
方法あるんだから そういう風にものすごい厳しく言うんです
直す見込みがあるんだから
それまたすぐできますよと
何億円も出すこそじゃないんです
すぐできますよと  それはお釈迦様の番目の真理なんですね
渇愛論というのは まあわかるかわからないかわかりません
勝手に喋ってることだからね
勝手に喋っている仏教ってのはちょっと理解難しいんです
ですから このヴィパッサナーするかどうかわかりませんだけど
この期待しないでありのままで確認してみるというね
その能力をね そのテクニックをね
身につく必要があるんですね
期待してやっちゃうと
まあそれでも全部もう脱線というか
もうリバースギアになったことになります
先には進めないんです
食べたら食べたで 美味しかったら美味しかったでね
そこでストップするんです
聞こえたら聞こえたと
そこでストップするしてみるんですね
次にそれについて妄想するのは
それが渇愛なんです 音が入ったら
まあ音について妄想する
強烈な渇愛なんですね
それで苦しみが出てくる
ですから この認識を磨くということで
認識方法を変えるということで
見るだけで止まってもらう
聞くだけで止まってもらう
味わっただけで止まってもらう
だから妄想しないで渇愛を増えないで止まってもらうということで
人は止まることじゃないんですよ
今一つ見たら 次に他のものを見るし
次の他のものを見るし
だからもう仕事はいっぱいありますよ
ずっともう限りなく見たり聞いたりしているんだから
死ぬまでやってるんだから
そこで見るものを一つ見て
それに何時間も妄想して
次のことを見ると見たことにもなってないんですね
だから考える人の頭が悪いと平気で言うんです
だって何にも考えない私が世の中の情報をいっぱい知ってるでしょうに
何も考えないんだからあんまりにもアホですよ
だから二 三分で十分です
二 三分ちょっとあれば情報をいじっちゃえば
世の中今こういう風になっているんだろうと
考えると知る暇がなくなっちゃうんですね
ですから この大体ね 考えることにはすごい執着していて
ものすごい欲があっていてね
渇愛の渇愛があるという
もう無意味なことを考えることがね
大変ありがたがっているしね
で 考える時はまあもう一旦我々はストップしているんですね
何も頭の中でもごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃに回転しているんだから
その間その 間で世の中でどんな変化が起きたかわからないんですね
それでまた また何か見たり
またそれについてまたごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ十年ぐらいごちゃごちゃ考えて
その間でどんな変化が起きたかわからないんですね
それでそうやって今日何か見て
また十年後で何か見てと
それつなげちゃうんですね
それが事実やと言うんだから
もう事実でも何でもないんでしょうし
人間関係で比べてみたっても同じことでしょうしね
人と喧嘩したら それがそのまま頭の中でもうごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃもう繁殖しちゃうんですね
そこで五年が経ってその人を見ても
あの五年前のことと今の人とすぐ繋げちゃうんです
その人は全く何だこりゃと訳も分からなくなっちゃう
ずっと変わっているんだからね
だから恨み憎しみってね
そういう風にあるもんですよ
頭が悪いんだからね 妄想しなかったらもう何のこともない
瞬時にそれを忘れちゃいます
忙しいんで そんなことを覚えておく暇もないんです
次の次の新しい情報が来るんだから
それ知っておかないと
まあそのこの見方をね
人間にはまずない ですから
その見方変えてもらうというためのこの実践方法なんです
妄想しないでやってみようと
では話をそろそろ ありがとうございます
ありがとうございます